hey everybody it's me and I'm back from
the dead this is unbelievable my tour
solo is on pause because the Impractical
Jokers national tour has started the
arena tour tickets are on sale for the
first leg of it right now at impractical
jokerslive.com we're coming to Reading
Pennsylvania we're coming to uh Stony
Brook we're coming to Pittsburgh Camden
New Jersey Boston we're coming to
Charleston South Carolina Charlotte
North Carolina Waterloo New York uh
Washington DC Niagara Falls Newark
Wallingford Belmont Park we're playing
that UBS Arena and the Prudential arena
in Jersey Island Milwaukee Rosemont
Seattle Portland I mean guys Utah Denver
Arlington Austin Sugar Land Columbus
Cleveland Detroit Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City I'm getting tired Nashville
Indianapolis and St Louis that's just
what's announced right now and it's all
on sale right now we're revving up right
now the show's gonna be a blast we
haven't been out in years hope to see
you there in practicejokerslive.com once
again I never promised You a Rose Garden
bringing the show down to Austin Texas
January 13th and 14th at the Vulcan and
then New York again Levittown New York
at Governors January 20th and 21st come
and check out all these shows more being
added all the time stay tuned get all
your Show tickets and all your show info
joeinfo.com also please check out we'll
see you in hell my movie podcast with
Pat Walsh we are over at we'll see uh
I'm sorry we're at patreon.com
wsiyhpodcast you can get all the new
episodes there and the back catalog is
available online wherever you get your
podcasts and finally Joey Rose's my barn
sandwich shop is now open seven days a
week at 11 30 a.m every day drinks and
sandwiches all day long come through
thank you for the support we've turned a
year old I can't believe we made it this
is amazing thank you guys we couldn't
have done it without you come see us and
if you want info about the barn sandwich
shop
joeyrosesnyc.com that thank you taste
buds they coming to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
tastes good hey taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds here I am and Chris
DiStefano the pigs new studio where he
does Chrissy chaos and hey babe
why am I alone I know I know I know we
said that I would be alone
but here I am alone
uh
uh it's listen I'm just going to come
clean with you guys we've been trying to
kind of dance around it for a while
with the show I know that Sal has been
gone
and uh it's something we were trying to
rectify
for a while I know that he did some hey
babes last week
but um you know unfortunately
uh his time is just cut in half and I
can't speak to his future on hey babe
but taste buds it sounds like
is going to be
me
[Applause]
who's back in the head
one's house good to see you buddy hey
did I show that pretty well you did yeah
good I was like am I not coming back
oh so these are from these are shirts A
lot's happened while I've been gone
these are shirts tell me who invested in
a gym I did I did it did you no no okay
these are from Dylan a Hornswoggle from
the WWE oh my boy yeah what up uh Dylan
you know as you know you know him he's a
big fan of the show he's he dm'd me and
and I was like Yo dude I'm a fan he's
like me too yeah he's a boy he's a boy
of mine yeah he was like let me send you
some merch so he sent me some shirts so
that's one of them this is
you know I never asked him I guess it is
yeah yeah let me put this right here and
then uh we got some uh
we got some other gifts here these are
from uh Chris Christina
who is a big fan
she comes to all of my shows she's very
nice all right
um and in a fun way not in a weird way
okay that's good uh but anyway she said
that here's the card let me ask you a
question though
do you find it hard and distracting I do
when the same people come to the same
shows all the time especially when
you're working on stuff that's all I
have buddy okay gotcha
no you've got a very devout small band
of followers yeah it could be tough when
like
be trying to work on stuff and tweak
stuff and change stuff and yes you love
the support you love the people that has
nothing they have nothing to do it's
nothing personal but because we get it a
lot I get a lot and a lot of times I'm
like oh my God man I just wish it was
new people because also I want to hear
someone who hasn't heard the material 10
times react to it
um I don't in all honesty I don't have a
ton of people that come show after show
after show yeah
she's very devoted and she has told me
that she likes watching the small tweaks
and the changes and watching it involved
and stuff so for them but if I have
friends and stuff I can't they I can't
see them yeah I can't I tell like if my
family comes I always say put them in
the back yeah
um yeah but I hear you I hear how that
could be distracting but she so she sent
us
she said this is a a small the second
small gift which is this because she
gave me a shirt it's for Sal you both
mentioned playing with these as kids now
you both have a set Jack Christmas
word I don't remember saying we played
with these did you I remember talking
about Jax yeah yeah I remember well here
you go you get two high balance they
still sell them in like that old school
way
well it says vintage toys on it 16 metal
jacks two balls I guess that's part of
it right
so 16 Jacks and only two balls must be a
trans party
is that funny I don't know I'm guys I'm
Rusty
I laughed at it you're coming back on
fire today thank you so much I I uh we
start on the wrong stuff with gifts I
should have just we definitely thinking
who cares I have not seen you the fans
haven't seen you I know so I I know you
guys joked that I was dead uh Kristen I
would never be that District I didn't
come back no I um I just was really
really busy with uh
touring and filming and and it just was
this just was literally no time it just
was one of those periods of times where
everything was happening all at once and
I was like oh [ __ ] I'm not even gonna
have a day off here for a while right so
thank you guys so much for for just you
know keeping the show going for the fans
and having the guests and and doing
everything I really truly appreciate it
uh it was it was our pleasure man it was
we had some fun I want to catch you up
on what's happening okay I'm hoping I'm
back now because especially after we get
this block and then I'll be in the clear
again for the next block and then I'm
done with filming great so I think I
think for you know I think right now
we're we're back in it great great the
uh no that's great um the yeah we missed
you we're happy to keep the show going
uh we had some fun guests
um we had some wild curve balls thrown
at us first of all I just want to say
thank you
thank you
we see the comments we see the reviews
thank you to the fans that stuck with us
through this thank you to the fans that
were really cool they were like Joe
you're holding it down we know Sal will
be back we love the show we're sticking
with you guys through the thick and thin
we appreciate it you guys are the best
to everybody that left your little one
star saying the show now is unbearable
and it's not what it don't come back
yeah Phoebe wanted to begin with yeah
beat it man like beat it if you were
somebody that goes oh I'm Gonna Leave a
one-star review because I used to love
it now I think it's beat it man we don't
want now that the show is back to normal
stay away we don't want you how can I
leave a one star review that's horrible
A free show though for two years because
someone's busy and this is not that's so
weird to me it's crazy is that really
people saying that yes somebody left a
review last night terrible uh it was or
two days I have one big update for you I
have the full Ronald McDonald costume in
my apartment oh all right well that's
something that's happened just so you
guys know from shout out that's amazing
all right so we got the costume
so that's we gotta do all right you're
still not with it
huh you still not with it no I'll do it
I'm so excited I haven't done it yet
though because you were busy and it was
like it kind of seemed dumb to do it
without you yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
right you're right but yeah we'll do it
we'll do it good
um but what else has happened we had
some fun guests while you were gone I
saw you had
um
uh cooge I'm saying that right guy oh no
that was cooge's first time right yeah
he came back Bobby Kelly is a great
barbecue um Ian Laura was interesting
Ian Laura came in and I said that I
don't know him Ian's a great guy yeah he
said that he thought that barbecue sauce
was considered red sauce
did you have a stroke I was like what
are you I kept you saying you were
raised in garbage like what are you
talking about dude it's like a red sauce
yeah he said because the color is red
all right it was nuts um who else was on
Corinne and Christina from guys we
[ __ ] yes that's a shame I missed those
guys that was fun my favorite week was
when Joe fought himself I had to fight
myself because Joe gotta and Steve bird
canceled no 20 minutes after they were
supposed to be there no I didn't hear
this no no taste buddies taste buddies
hold on real quick whoa do not go after
them do not I'm serious don't stop you
guys were trolling Steve Burke go after
him no they were
[Music]
that is wholly unprofessional dude they
canceled 20 minutes after they were
supposed to be there wait why and I was
sitting on my couch why they said
because they were lighting the the they
were doing the tree lighting in Times
Square and the traffic was bad and I
said you ready for this I go well just
just make your way down here we'll make
it work and Steve was like well that's
the thing we already turned around and
started heading toward our studio and I
go these guys they didn't want to come
down the traffic was rough they saw an
opportunity to beeline it for what they
had to do wait they were at the tree I
messed up they were coming from Jim and
Sam oh sure sure okay they were coming
from Jim and Sam uh they left Jim and
Sam 15 minutes late
uh and then they called us from the car
and said we're 15 minutes late we're in
the car they were supposed to they're
already supposed to be him right in our
part in my apartment and uh they I was
like all right you're 15 don't worry
about it so when will you be here they
said we'll be here at 11 40.
I was like all right well that's 40
minutes late but we could make this work
and then at 11 40 they called and said
we can't make it
and apparently the fans kind of lit up
Steve a little bit not Joe I don't know
I haven't spoken listen to me you either
light them both up but you don't like
them yesterday went after the other I'm
sure they went after Joe too I just
don't have the relationship with you
where he's going to text me and be like
what the [ __ ]
uh you know all right maybe Joe never
talks to me ever again well exact
Revenge let's get booked on their pod
and then we'll go up to this I mean we
definitely need to go on their pod and
and raise check out their pods Two Cool
Moms yes check out Steve's uh Steve
Burns new hour special on Amazon Prime
the last the last late night the last
late night yeah Steve has a really good
grade we've been on I think you've been
on it he has a really good comedy
podcast called uh stand up comedy
related podcast called uh comedy pinion
yeah it's a great job it's a fun one I
I'm known Steve I like them both very
much but I've known Steve for all of my
years in comedy basically and he's one
of my best friends of the world I love
the guy which is why it hurt that he did
that to me
he truly is one of my best friends no
it's they're they're they're both great
guys what else has happened pimp well I
saw this new food Trend if you guys want
to check it out sure oh right before we
talk about this and you also Miss
chocolate covered rich
chocolate covered Ritz Rich at Christmas
time did a limited edition no they
didn't it was chocolate chocolate
flavored or chocolate covered chocolate
covered babe no they didn't and they
were delish you had them yeah I bought
them you had them on camera I didn't
have them on camera I bought them and I
ate them are they still available
wow fudge in a Buttery Golden Crown it
works buddy it tastes like a pot but one
of those Pokey sticks uh is that what
it's called Pokemon I don't know okay
it's really good really wow and they've
never done that before you talked about
this the Mountain Dew fruit cake flavor
fruit quake
disgusting oh it's not it doesn't sound
good
and then we also talked about the new
food trend of where where people
families are dumping food on the table
for everybody to just oh I've seen that
it's barbaric animal I could picture the
Mountain Dew um the Mountain Dew like in
the conference room when they're like we
got this new fruit
this new fruit drink it's basically for
the season it's basically it's like a
fruit cake and we'll be taking uh you
know all entries for what we could name
it and that guy who thought of fruit
quake
he got promoted yeah he got promoted
yeah he probably like literally said
fruit quake and just pulled his bowls
out onto the table he's sleeping in a
brass bed gifted to him yeah Mountain
Dew I mean you couldn't be more on top
he was probably like fruit quick I'll
see you [ __ ] next year man yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's August he's like I'm
taking the rest of the year off he's
like I got it fruit Quake [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you you're okay [ __ ] you yeah yeah I'm
out wait what is this trend pimp I'm not
really even sure but I've seen it around
tick tock oh no oh no oh come on no you
know the kitchen sink is the most filthy
place in the house that's disgusting
this is disgusting why though but also
why why
and they're keeping the dirty Bowls in
the sink to the left of it
that is so stupid this is for views I
mean by the way the salad is colorful
by the way they're about to are they
about to wash everything in the salad or
in the sink
this is disgusting
why
why are they doing you know how many
germs are in yourself no no he's not
saying why is it disgusting oh oh he's
saying why Lord okay okay first of all
she's still going then they put French
dressing on it you garbage you garbage
oh no no there it goes that that's
that's the person you're dealing with uh
now they're gonna are they gonna toss it
oh now she washes her hands
this is this is just is this a trend or
is this one video
you [ __ ] pig yeah you she is she
might be a nice person in real life but
this is a strike against a character and
credibility
oh my God
that is who you're dealing with so on
appetizing and unappealing oh the Dr
when it got to the dressing you knew
exactly you were doing with not just
French but also Ranch and then Wishbone
wish hold the [ __ ] phone hold the
phone she took dirty dishes dirty dishes
out she didn't even wash it look now
she's making hunch she's putting on
hunts
she's making pudding tomato paste
directly she just put wait
he just put in cheddar cheese with
Velveeta
she put in in the dirty part of the sink
without washing it she put in pasta
tomato sauce out of a can shredded
cheddar cheese cheese whiz and what
looks like pepperoni
so if you show up to a friend's party
and this is how they're prepping the
food what do you do
a conversation happens immediately
because I need to know what's happening
for the future of our relationship I
want to know why they think this is a
good idea why they don't think it's
disgusting why they feel the need to do
it like because just put them in two big
bowls like there's no reason except for
like clicks I I don't think this is a
real thing how about that I don't think
she's having a party and I don't think
she'd serve anyone like that I think
that this is someone looking for views
you overestimate this Society we live in
this is where we're because honestly I
don't understand the food on the table
without plates
there you go what is it supposed to be
like what so everybody can reach in with
their hands because it's fun
because these parents is it for toddlers
is that what because probably because
these parents are such numb nuts and
none of them can discipline their kids
at all so the only way to get their kids
to eat is by dumping food on the table
instead of saying to your kid eat your
dinner right or you go to bed hungry
right because everybody now isn't a is a
child abuser for disciplining their kid
so this is where we're at and I also
think the hipsters think they're part of
the minimalist movement
yeah without yeah the hipsters whose
parents are paying for their apartment
the way dude it's not like it's not like
not for those of you just listening not
watching it's not like nachos and stuff
like that it's spaghetti it's food
that's gonna get all over your hands and
all over the other food there's a
certain containment with nachos
are you okay no
what is there's a certain containment
with anything you dip you don't double
dip yeah what what's the what's the
psychology behind why they feel that's
fun because I don't see it as I don't
see it because is it strictly for
children eating is that the thing I
promise you it is because people are
ruled every one of these videos and
pictures I see it's with kids
people are ruled by their children
they're ruled by their children which is
why you have 65 year old people on Tick
Tock that aren't promoting this is
piping hot sauce she's putting on a
vinyl table disgusting dude
it's just look at this look at these
pigs this family of pigs this has got to
be not the kid's fault it's a parrot's
fault I should just threw the meatballs
right on the table to the floor yeah
throw a meatball on the floor oh God
look at this
by the way you can get freshly grated
Parmesan cheese from a local Deli as a
for the same exact prices as the craft
just a little life that neighborhood is
nowhere near a local Deli that
neighborhood is only near so the kid
thinks okay this is like
unorthodox this is like against the
rules so this is that's the appeal to
the kids good watch them dig in watch
them at least the little girl has the
sense to have a fork the little girl has
a fork even she knows my mother is an
animal look at what she is doing to us
right now this is disgusting by the way
it says our first dump dinner first of
all a dump dinner
this is what we're living in but she
says it's her first but then she's so so
confident
confident she's dumping food I know but
she's doing it with gusto
all right you should be really slouched
and weeping if you're eating this meal
there's only one yeah you should be
preparing this like a military Chef
during World War II
that should be no joy Jesus Christ I did
want to know what you guys think of the
new 3D meat that's coming out to replace
regular meat uh I actually would give it
a shot what is that what is that they're
manufacturing geez I die for two months
and uh we're we're printing meat they're
manufacturing they think they've figured
out a way to use to use cells from
animals and stuff like that
to create
meats you can have meat without killing
animals you
I mean I would try it why is it why are
you printing meat as opposed to just
preparing it I don't know you don't have
to destroy an animal's life they're
making this without animals right but
3D printer to make it well what how else
would you make it you're like the Farms
would turn they're like growing it
they're creating meat from nothing
you know what I mean are we taking
Liberties but what a 3D printer is are
we is this like the same technology is
it like we're not do they shut that off
and then they also print can print like
a plastic house probably it's the same
machine
they will print the tablecloth system I
don't understand 3D printing well it's
getting to the point where they can
print you a new organ in the future
that's what's hap gonna happen they're
going to be able to print you all right
so we're taking the word print now we're
using the word print but the word print
is Antiquated it's not this is not
really what this is it's not a 3D
printer it's not going to print you an
organ but that's what 3D printing is
what's the difference 3D printing would
make a three-dimensional bowl or
something what's that's what this is
making a three-dimensional item it just
happened the item just happens to be me
look at it it looks real
I need it so this is meat made from
cells alone and and printed and like
kind of raw material yeah
but but I I just don't understand right
the printer
it has to have
a finite amount of things that it is
compatible with
that can go through its system and be
ejected out of the thing
like I I just don't understand exactly
how it's Limitless like how is it
printing food that's that's not printing
anymore well have you seen the houses
they printed
homes homes
homes
I've seen Model Homes what do you I
don't understand what you're confused
about it's the same thing except just
different material
so you're telling me this machine right
here you could throw some cells in there
and get yourself a burger or you throw
some you could throw some uh some some
some some some kind of resin in there
and get yourself home no machine I don't
think you're I no no I don't think
you're I might be wrong obviously I
don't understand how this works I don't
think you're throwing cells into the
machine I think you're creating the meat
first and then you're feeding whatever
that substance is into the printer and
then the printer is it's just
I think it's raw materials printing the
meat I think you're confusing the word
print with paper and ink sure well no
I'm making this distinction right here
like we're just talking about we're
calling it a printer 3D printing is
manufacturing basically right it's but
we should be calling it printed the
reason it's called printing processing
something well yeah but the reason it's
called printing is because it comes from
an image on a computer the way you would
print out paper
right
if you had a photo on your computer
right you could print it
that's this like if you look at 3D
printers there's a three-dimensional
image on a on a computer and then it
prints out
that house is printed
it's pretty but what are we talking
about
what is coming out of the printer to
make that house
let's get an expert let's get an expert
bring them on the Pod I really don't
know how to explain it
it feels like a scam it doesn't is it
the wave of the future is it going to be
one of the best new inventions of the
century I
think I think probably it's going to
change everything and and it will
destroy us and we'll we'll figure out a
way to this point if you've written
stakes and homes what can't you print
think about the what the leaps this
could make for cannibals you could print
cannibals
is that ethical you could print
cannibals human flesh they could just
eat human flesh finals is that ethical
why not is it a big Market I doubt it's
probably a small Market it's probably
one of your bit your smaller markets I
mean at what point are we gonna be like
you can print a human
yeah I mean well they're already cloning
people hello fresh happy New Year happy
New Year it's hellofresh you got you
guys goals as we all do some people call
them resolutions
I uh yeah I don't like to put labels on
things so I'm just gonna say that
there's stuff I want to get done in this
new year and hellofresh is helping me
achieve them why because I can skip the
grocery store and take control of my
time and my budget with delicious
recipes delivered right to the door I
love hello fresh I love the recipes I
love the robust flavors in these recipes
I love that they're filling portions and
I love that you can get it all ready in
less than 15 minutes it's enjoyable
eating well is at the top of my things
to do for 2023 and it's comforting to
know that you're always going to get top
quality stuff with hellofresh
ingredients travel from Farm to you in
less than seven days so you know that
they're fresh I love it I'm running
around all the time I I have a bar and
sandwich shop I do these podcasts I do
stand up I tour I travel
it it really helps with all the planning
and running around I have to do to
random places in each day to come home
and know everything is right there ready
to go for me and it's going to be not
just a satisfying meal but a meal that's
good for me uh anyway go to
hellofresh.com
tastebuds18
hellofresh.com
tastebuds18 use the promo code
tastebuds18. you get 21 free meals plus
free shipping that's amazing
hellofresh.com taste buds18 and use
promo code taste buds 18. for 21 free
meals plus free shipping hellofresh
America's number one meal kit
folks let's talk sponsors and let's talk
Noom Noom is a great thing if you're
looking to lose some weight uh we're
motivated a lot of us to lose weight
especially this time of year hey it's
the New Year those resolutions are
kicking in
maybe we put on a few extra pounds over
the holidays maybe the holidays just
allowed us to double down on our bad
habits uh maybe we picked up some new
bad eating habits who knows whatever it
is but we're all kind of in that boat of
saying I'd like to maybe drop a few or
at least many of us are in that boat
um I like Noom quite a bit why because
help me first first of all recognize
eating habits that I was doing uh like
for instance like fomo you know uh you
know you'd see uh something that wasn't
good for you
um but and you were already on a diet or
eating right and you'd break it because
you go what am I going to do you only
live once I got to eat this double meat
pepperoni cheese steak thing and then
the next thing you know that that sort
of lets the the chain of dominoes start
falling and and your habits get bad bad
worse worse worse uh because you know
that one bad decision lit the fuse for
me Noom kind of helped me understand
why I was doing that and how I could do
it a little bit less uh or or a lot less
quite frankly
um I I like the way they explain certain
foods to me and why certain foods are
smarter to eat than others and it goes
beyond just hey this is healthy and this
isn't uh and I think the app is
incredibly easy to use it keeps you
motivated and it keeps your your head in
the game I like that Noom uses
psychology uh because losing weight as
they say starts with your brain and it's
a program built to help you understand
the science behind your eating choices
and why you have those Cravings it's
flexible and it focuses on progress
instead of perfection
active first-time numbers lose an
average of 15 pounds in 16 weeks and 95
percent of customers say new weight is a
good long-term solution so
stay focused on what's important
uh and Noom weight psychology-based
approach is going to help you do that
sign up for your free trial today at
noon.com tastebud singular that's
n-o-m.com
tastebud and you're going to sign up for
your free trial today and also by the
way check out noom's first ever book the
new mindset a deep dive into the
psychology of behavior change available
to buy now wherever books are sold
what's up
what's bad life Since You Been Gone do
you have any stories since I've been
gone on uh do I have a story I don't
know man dude I just I've had like a day
off a month maybe I don't even know I'm
just in a was in a tizzy in a frenzy We
were finishing filming season 10 in the
next three weeks
full season which is like holy [ __ ] so
and then um we are waiting to see they
have an option for 11 we don't know yet
if we're gonna do 11 yet
um we'd like to we're having fun the
show has been a change of pace with the
guests and stuff right we've been having
a lot of fun it's opened up a lot of
creative different avenues that we might
not have been doing before so it's like
it has been a little revitalizing
um you know but I also am ready to do
other projects and ready to work on my
special and all that stuff so we'll see
what happens I'm just taking it day to
day right now yeah it's a long time it's
11 years it's been the the issue with
the show and the touring rules is
exactly what happened to us it's like I
don't have enough time to not even do
like new projects I don't even have time
I didn't have time to do this if we
didn't have the setup that we had it
would have been a major issue we had to
take a major Hiatus right you know so
it's just it is it can get like a little
bit of like pretty grueling I mean
everyone has their version of this but
I'm just you asked me how I was doing so
good I just had my head down I was
really focused and I really trying to do
a lot of work you know the last time
it's nothing exciting for me to report
back like of why people missed me I just
was working a lot all right
yeah yeah it's like everybody in the
country I hear you yeah yeah I did want
to just to go back to the robots I saw I
saw a few great movies we'll talk about
they're starting to get jobs now in
McDonald's and they're working alongside
the humans
Chipotle's chippy okay that's cute you
name it chippy and you and you and you
basically you you you personify it so
that the people around it that it's
going to take over don't feel threatened
immediately dude it's uh we're not in a
good way we're not in a good way you got
robots working in restaurants you got
people eating food off the table
you got other people making their their
party platters in their sink I mean it's
just we're we're just we're it's the
life hacks life hacks you heard of your
first people life hacks have been our
undoing that's it life hacks are our
undoing yeah everybody got so obsessed
with life hacks I think life hacks are
even more prevalent now because of tick
tock on people wanting to have used so I
think the the ad the invention of tick
tock
is forcing people to come up with hacks
because that's one of the currencies on
Tick Tock it's just insane man it's just
I mean when it what's being made what's
gonna be made out of the toilet tell me
they're gonna be like first Lysol the
toilet make it nice and clean and then
when it has fresh water what are they
gonna do with it I mean it's punch bowls
it's prison stuff you make toilet work
right I mean it's prison it's prison
stuff it's just disgusting
how was your how was your holiday
I I had coveted for for most of it and
then I got better just in time to be
able to see my family at Christmas okay
I mean it was like down to the wire
Christmas miracle yeah it was but uh he
missed Thanksgiving too your
Thanksgiving didn't seem like a happy
time yeah yeah I don't want to talk
about it
uh Thanksgiving wasn't great but uh
goodness but Christmas was actually very
nice okay Christmas was nice I think I
think once I was faced with the idea
that I might have to sit alone in my
apartment
on my favorite holiday ever thanks and
just no Christmas okay
because of covid and just deal with it
and like it just reframed all of
Christmas so when things turned around
and I got to see my family it was such a
surprise I think we all just kind of
really appreciated it yes okay you know
I didn't even care like I didn't even
my mom got me the God bless her but she
got me the wrong present
the wrong presence yeah like the wrong
size or or you asked her something she
purchased something wrong yeah and she
was the wrong thing and she goes did I
get the wrong thing and I was like um
yeah but it's okay and she was like well
what I'll return it let me get you the
right thing and I was just kind of like
I don't care it's okay like I don't know
it just kind of reframed Christmas like
there was no importance on the wrong
stuff you're focus on the wrong stuff
all the focus was just on hey Network
here if you didn't have covet and you
went to regular Christmas and your mom
was like I got the wrong thing you would
have had it out I would have been like
tomorrow morning I will convene at the
dining room table let's start the return
process
I'll show you exactly what I need yeah
no can you say what it what the thing
was or was it not even worth saying she
got me a bunch of little stuff but one
of the one of the main things I wanted
was I wanted the Godfather movies
in 4k okay the set and she got it in
1080P she got it in just regular Blu-ray
yeah she's we that was a 1080p what is
this 2016. that's what Blu-ray is
Blu-ray is 1080p no I know you nailed it
I know I'm saying what is this 2016. oh
she has to oh I mean the resolution has
come so far yeah I mean I just it was
something that I would I buy a lot of
moves it's 4K 4000 P I don't know I
don't know what it means and all I know
now is at Best Buy there's an 8K TV 8K
has been 8K has been hanging around in
the shadows for a long time but it's
just been overpriced for the consumer
level and also they tell you at the
store they go you can buy it but you
can't see anything in 8k yet that's what
happened when 4K came out yeah they
could buy 4K but none of the no stations
are broadcasting in 4k yeah the only way
you could watch 4ks if you get a 4K DVD
I started replacing some of my favorite
films that I own already with 4K copies
oh you're you're actually you're
actually going and I have a 4K player
and a 4K TV okay I've had it for a while
but the discs now are finally starting
to come wait so I have a Blu-ray player
is that not a 4K player no you it has to
be a 4K maybe I do have a 4K player well
your Xbox series X or your PlayStation 5
are both I have an X yeah those are 4K
players I have the PS5 I never opened
the end I would love for you to come by
my house and guide me through that
process
plugging it into your TV
it what do you think is going to happen
the last time I plugged in something was
the Xbox before it and I plugged it in
and I my had good intentions uh Q came
over we downloaded that Friday the 13th
game but I plugged it in and now there's
like such it's such a barrier to entry
you you turn it on then you had to like
update all the software then you had to
make a user then you have to join the
Xbox Gold then you make a username then
you have to go download the game onto
the thing and then that could take a
while and then you turn it on and it's
like you got to do a warm-up mode and I
was like I opened the [ __ ] thing and
it took me three hours to begin playing
a game I'm like there's got to be a
better way I think you'll get when I
realized just playing Nintendo I think
you'll get it a little faster yeah
uh that's coffee just showed up I will
guide you through it yeah I want to
bring over a game called The Quarry
I know the game it's by 2K right I think
shout out to I think it's by 2K
David David uh Arquette in it
I believe he's in it Lance Hendrickson's
in it Ted rhamey it's a horror movie
basically yes yes shout out I want to
shout out 2K Games okay I've recently uh
uh became Pals I met when uh Ronnie 2K
Ronnie Singh uh he's uh with a basically
a brand ambassador the face of like 2K
oh really yeah we were like talking to
him about you know doing a project
together or whatever and he said good
dude and I had been going through uh uh
touring through um
North
California and he's from that area and
he came to one of my show he came to my
last show on the tour actually cool yeah
really nice guy uh and I and uh two yeah
so they they're okay there's good work
yeah they do yeah yeah I saw the game I
was like I saw the trailer and I was
like I have to play this thanks pip
what's that
[ __ ] I got an Americano that's yours
Pike Place thanks buddy
all right we should get to the battle
yeah let's get to the battle uh what was
I saying though I don't know whatever
Impractical Jokers video game yeah
that'd be pretty cool um you should do
like Tony Hawk Underground you guys just
skate for no reason yeah yeah uh there
was talk about there's um there's a new
app coming out that has like literally
10 10 games in it and it's it's all
different games it's all of us and on it
there's always been an app for years
there's a version of the app they keep
on redoing it and updating and now this
new one is a big big undertaking like
they've been working on it for like a
year and it's got like all the stuff
from the show it's like really really
drilled down on stuff so that but it's
like fun little games that aside if you
could design it the way you want what
kind of game would it be
scroller RPG I think I would do I think
I would do like RPG and literally make
it like go like go out into the public
and say it would be your shoes to do
stuff and see what happens and go like
as Choose Your Own Adventure what would
be your skill set you know my skill set
I would be if if they gave like the
power rankings that I would be the low
power ranking
I don't know my skill set would just be
to be like um
I don't know to just say no
to things but uh I think it'd be funny
if you did do a Joker's RPG but actually
had fantastic elements in it where it
almost was like
a Zelda and it's like a Zelda that's fun
listen 2K let me know let's do it yeah
or uh yeah what else I mean they made
board games and stuff oh you know what
you know what I wanted to do for a
really long time and if if someone knows
someone or you're watching or you do
this I think that impractical jokes
would make a great slot machine in
casinos with all the different
characters and rules and games we have
and all of us I believe it's not one
already they you know I've seen I've
seen them like I've seen like television
based ones I brought this up like no
joke like eight years ago and we talked
to some guy and then like it kind of
fell through but I think people would
would play it you know like I think they
were playing Atlantic City hell yeah
yeah yeah yeah all those like casinos
like through the country I feel like it
would be a hit there
the uh are we too low energy today
no no no I think it's a great episode
are you okay I just feel a lot of
pressure but just shoot we're just
shooting the [ __ ] up I do a lot of
pressure no fresh because you're back
I'm like did we did we did we take too
long again yeah just let's do us if if
we end up yelling we end up yelling if
not we don't and then it is I almost
feel bad yelling at you today nah nah
people want it yeah people want it but
that's why I hope we can deliver we
don't fake the elves if they come they
come if they don't they don't then it's
just well enough for these niceties the
question is saltier
saltier sweet what are you guys doing
I think
I think we have to go salty just right
out oh yeah oof uh I don't know if I'll
be prepared I think we got to come back
swinging all right geez what's your
first battle today
folks let's talk about raycon the
earbuds that are great that work great
that sound great that sinks seamlessly
with your phone and are a hell of a lot
better priced than all those other
high-priced earbud things that your
options that are out there Ray Conn's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever they've got optimized
gel tips for perfect in-ear fit uh these
earbuds are so comfortable and they will
not budge trust me I've used them I like
them uh raycon gives you about eight
hours of play time and 32 hours of
battery life uh raycons are priced just
right as I said you're gonna get quality
audio at half the price of the other
premium audio Brands it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds have over 50
000 five-star reviews uh I like that
there are three custom customizable
sound profiles uh that you can select
from I like the the tap functions that
the earbuds have I find them very easy
to use I've used earbuds where the tap
function is not I don't know what it is
it's it's confusing or it's or it just
doesn't work great and I'm skipping
things when I'm not meaning to and
things of that nature I didn't have any
of those problems with the the
functionality of the tapping with uh
with raycon and I think that's very very
cool and I also like the noise isolation
I mean these are these are really built
for a solid solid all-encompassing
listening experience uh I've used them I
like them I'm going to keep using them
so go to buy raycon.com tastebuds and
get 15 off today
buy recon.com
tastebuds today to get 15 off your
raycon order that's by raycon.com taste
buds to score 15 off by raycon.com taste
buds folks better help this show is
sponsored by betterhelp
and I'm glad they're sponsoring us I
like better help a lot all right and I'm
gonna have you today go to
betterhelp.com tastebuds to get on your
way to being your best self
uh better help why you ask why better
help versus anything else I will tell
you why uh they're going to help you be
at your best uh they're offering you the
help you need they're offering it in a
convenient uh way to get that help uh
and they're letting you just cut out all
the BS and get to solving the problems
you need to solve for yourself
this better help is all about
functionality and and getting in there
and getting the work done and not going
through a bunch of bureaucratic nonsense
with with systems and whatever else
trying to just get the first step going
better help is letting you take action
and take control immediately and that's
a good thing when you're at your best
you can do great things sometimes you
know life is Gonna Get You bogged down
you're going to feel overwhelmed you
feel like not showing up and when that
all happens you just can't function the
way you want to so working with a
therapist can help you get close or
closer to the best version of you uh and
that's good you're going to feel
empowered when you do that and you know
that makes you feel just more prepared
to take on what you need to take on in
life whatever life is throwing at you
you're going to have a better way of
handling all that and it can be tough we
all know it can be tough again I can't
stress enough I like what better help is
doing you know what I love what better
help is doing and I don't mean that in a
modeling way I'm very serious if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try which I
know many of us do and again get put off
by this daunting process that comes
along with it
worry no more give better help a try
it's a great option so live a more
empowered life
therapy can help you get there visit
betterhelp.com tastebuds today you're
going to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash taste buds well which
one do you want to do we I put up I
think the the classic of the three
battles is crumb cake carrot cake okay I
think maybe we start there okay and then
later that's the one that was posted
last okay but still it's fine okay
you want to do salty
yeah
I haven't yelled at and insulted it in a
while
all right you you insult me first why
because because I don't know I just all
right all right should we just do I love
you maybe it's just I love you yeah we
could still fight after I love you
you're right oh that's right that's why
you do it yeah all right that's good to
see you I love you all right
I love you no matter what happens I love
you no matter what happens I love you
time to
b-a-t-t-l-e boots
dude I haven't done that chant in weeks
you you haven't done it with the gas
yeah I do battle I do battle buds by
myself okay I just yell it out at the
beginning but I don't uh I don't do the
no I didn't do anything Chris has not
done the opening songs either right oh
it's nice it's a little something like
you know for us we got crumb cake
versus
carrot cake your team carrot cake the
carrot cake now let me tell you
something this isn't going to be an easy
battle because crumb cake is great when
it's when crumb cake is done right the
ultimate crumb that one from the that's
all just buttery Rich goodness up here
and a good crumb cake is as good as
anything and I really am a fan of a good
crumb cake but there's a lot of bad
crumb cake and also if I had to take
them
in a microcosm if you put two plates in
front of me and push them forward and
one was a carrot cake and one was a
crumb cake I'm a little carrot cake
carrot cake is less accessible it's more
of uh I you know you don't think to have
at least for me I have it every once in
a while and I'm always like why don't I
have carrot cake all the time I change
my mind about what cakes I like I was
really heavy into red velvet
and then I transferred it to a Tres
Leches for a while and I what I do is I
eat those cakes at occasions until I get
sick of it and now I'm on carrickane
I'll tell you how much I want carrot
cake
three nights ago
for New Year's Eve I made a carrot cake
from scratch really scratch
the icing the the actual cake everything
how many carrots you use in a carrot
cake it was three cups of shredded
carrots okay it was it took it was fun
shredding them I wore a glove so I
wouldn't slice my thumb off okay I will
say there's a reason you don't have
carrot cake more often to answer your
question
because most of the time
it's kind of gross it's often served ice
cold which I don't care for
uh it's got nuts in it frequently which
I hate I substitute pecans for uh
walnuts for pecans I hate nuts in
anything except like the way I'm eating
them now with the sugary whatever but
like or like or like I'll I'll eat a
rate I'll eat a trail mix but nuts
inside which I take on a waldorf salad
I'll throw it across the room I'll just
throw it across your all right eat out
of that pig sink what about a bad water
or a shower a a a Chinese like peanut
dish
no never you don't like that yeah you
don't like nuts and food no no never I
hate because you're like nuts no hate it
you don't like a nice macadamia nut
cooker I it sickens me
I like a select amount of nuts yeah I
like him in a certain way pecan pie get
out of my face wow so you're opposed to
nuts unless they're loose in your hand
yeah in a trail mix yes yes really yeah
yes wow yes interesting though you said
you like trail mix yeah trail mix has
raisins yeah raisins are also a
component of Cheesecake that mixed with
the nuts yeah in a carrot cake you mean
yeah sorry you're a carrot cake yeah I
find that off-putting but you like it in
the trail mix yes odd I find carrot cake
off look let's start here
carrots got no [ __ ] business poking
their nose into dessert you got no
business on paper you would think but
then you bite into that carrot cake and
you say oh my whole my eyes are open to
the glory it's up there with the corn
muffin how dare you beat it ain't your
territory did you know he didn't like a
corn muffin it's listen you don't like
cornbread listen cornbread's fine it's
okay corn muffin is cornbread it's okay
corn muffin's fine it's okay you're
gonna try to step in the same ring as
blueberry are you not no I'm not are you
nuts carrot you're gonna step in the
same realm as chocolate are you not
scary get out of here I disagree I
disagree I think Cara is doing something
no other cake is doing except for maybe
a fruitcake which I don't really get
down with by the way Mountain Dew is a
new thing called the fruit quake and
that guy got a promotion uh we talked
about it I know oh
I mean I was being uh
um a little fact about the history uh
she
see I feel like Mr Rogers Neighborhood
who do you think's pounding at the door
what's that pimp
okay all right good all right who was
that uh the FedEx guy oh you talked to
him like he was your cousin oh yeah he's
a fedexer you know him no no yeah that
was a nice New York City exchange see
this is this this this is this
generation very friendly to to one
another very respectful of one another
yet delete out of the sink right it
doesn't make any sense right yeah
I did just want to say that uh carrot
Cake's invention was because carrots
used to be sweetener in the Middle Ages
well that makes sense because they had
no other choice honestly dude they had
no other option yeah they didn't have
sorry they didn't have Kane they didn't
have processed sugar yeah well I mean
but listen to me listen to me you're
gonna step into the roots
they came in and they proved it I can't
say they don't have a place in any cake
because they do it's a staple people
love it and and it works but it works
but let's talk turkey let's talk turkey
fine let's talk what you're up against
crumb cake AKA coffee cake AKA Drake's
coffee cake an entire Seinfeld episode
devoted wait to this case you're gonna
hit your call you're gonna hit your
crumb cake wagon to a Drake's coffee
cake dude I'm talking about a gourmet
artisanal cake here dude please are you
kidding me I made it I know what goes
into that [ __ ] as a matter of fact
the ingredients come together in a way
that I mean coffee cake is just it's
kind of like middle of the road carrot
cake is doing things man this is raisins
there's pecans there's carrots there's
butter this the cream cheese icing and
you can't deny the cream cheese icing
because I know that you like red velvet
a little birdie told me I got news for
you
cream cheese icing on a red velvet love
it cream cheese icing on a carrot cake
grosses me out a carrot cake has been
around since the it said 1800s red
velvet I I recall red velvet getting
popular about 10 years ago I don't know
where do you think red velvet no pun
intended you can't hold the crumb to red
velvet cake
red velvet is like it was my favorite
cake two cakes ago yeah but I got it I
realized something it it it lacks the
depth and flavor profile of a carrot
cake go to okay okay it could be a moist
the red is just dyed I'm gonna hit you
it's just a sponge cake with cream
cheese icing oh dare you how I love it
do you love pumpkin do you love fall
flavors there's nutmeg there's all spice
in a carrot cake let me tell you it's
delicious it's superb even let me tell
you something let me tell you something
you hit up any of your renowned bakeries
let's let's use Magnolia as the beacon
they're going to have a character Famous
by made famous By Sex In The City Is
that who made them famous yes well they
were staple of New York and then Sex in
the City made them internationally
Magnolia Bakery known for what they're
cupcakes that's that's what the big
thing is
because I go to Magnolia how often do
you go to Magnolia
once a year do they have a character
hey
and a lightning instant fast Google
search pulls up cake and cupcake
Magnolia yeah they look pretty good to
be honest they look delicious what do
you what do you so what is this now you
do an underhanded [ __ ] yeah that was a
lie yeah welcome back
they thought it couldn't be checked if
you want to fight underhanded go ahead
you just made a statement that you go
there all the time and they don't carry
that let me tell you something him
didn't check you let me tell you
I haven't who are you what's this guy's
name that the line governor oh Santos
Santos all right buddy tell you
something
all right for the last eight episodes of
this podcast you know how many lies
you've gotten away you've been gone you
you miss this
baby listen to me the last eight
episodes of this podcast you've been
gone I've been nothing but overhanded
you know why because I respected who sat
across
wow
you only discredit yourself right now
you're literally saying I lie to win I
don't care well people with Integrity
care accepted that I am the heel of this
show and this is what I do you can't
just say you're the healed the people
will decide if you're the ill all right
they have you're right they message me
I gotta tell you you don't love nutmeg
clove cinnamon no dude oh God no I'll
tell you
October November December are my
favorite months for a lot of reasons one
of them being the fall flavors I love
the fall and I like those flavors
occasionally in something whatever if
you're gonna talk to me though about a
slice of cake the thing that I have to
make a special treat out of the thing
that I can't have every day the thing
that I could can only go to Once in the
week and enjoy and you tell me do you
want to occupy that enjoyable beautiful
seven minute experience with nutmeg and
raisins and nuts and carrots I'm gonna
tell you no Take a Walk that's crazy you
want to talk to me about coffee cake
it's called
coffee cake because it is the gold
standard of dessert cakes it goes with
coffee or that doesn't make it a gold
standard oh it just makes it the one
that they want to go with coffee you
know what it is the coffee cake
I will eat a carrot cake with a coffee
right in front of you and enjoy it all
you could do anything you could eat an
Italian hoagie with a coffee you could
eat anything with a car it doesn't
matter so what here's my point here's my
point certain things go together and my
point is this dude coffee cake crumb
cake that was the gold standard that is
the cake that Sebastian Maniscalco you
said the joke about having the entimens
in case the company shows up sure that
is the gold standard middle American
household or middle class American
household that went down when the
friends showed up coffee cake is great I
love it for the first
few bites without a doubt for the first
few bites your senses are exploding but
then it is very very sugary and too
sweet too fast and I believe the reason
they decide to pair with coffee cake is
the coffee cuts through that sweetness
with its bitterness
it beautifully the coffee cake it's just
a big fat crumb and it's fun at first
but that's the only texture it has
Carrot Cake takes you through on a ride
carrot cake has the snap of the carrot
it has the pack up back up
the snap of the carrot what do you mean
by that yeah because if you shred
piece crunch out of your carrot
all right the sweet little sweetness
from the carrot the fall flavors from
the nutmeg and everything like that it's
moist it's it's flavor profile is moist
but this Crunch and then the creamy
cream cheese icing is so creamy so it
makes for spongy creamy crunchy it's
great and then and the raisin is still
chewy so it's just got a lot going on
and all those flavors really work
together and come together crumb cake is
one thing it's just a big ball of sweet
crumb it's the same texture it's the
same taste it's the same consistency
through into and through I think that
carrot cake offers more to the person
consuming it I also did this version
which I love and it's how most carrot
cakes are I did the three different
cakes three cakes on top of your nine
inch
uh actual sponge part with the cream
cheese layered in between and it's just
wonderful it's such a satisfying don't
make it sound like that coffee cake
doesn't have that element where you
could eat through the cake and still be
getting icing in the middle of the cake
not just the cat doesn't need icing
coffee doesn't have the crumb it doesn't
have the crumb
s crumb cake it doesn't have the crumb
crumb layer throughout it crumb cake
doesn't need it doesn't need it later
crumb cake let me tell you something I
understand what you're saying that that
that that
um uh carrot cake brings a certain pop
that you don't get every day whatever I
think that that hurts it I think that
means that you can't have it as often
because it gets old quick secondly I
think it means
that it is a hell of a gamble if you get
a bad piece of it you're in for a bad
ride coffee cake crumb cake on the other
hand always reliable and coffee crumb
cake is something I could eat every day
I could eat a piece of crumb cake every
morning as like in the way you could eat
a blueberry muffin every morning first
of all uh crumb cake the the actual cake
is a [ __ ] after thought and
especially no offense especially in
Entenmann's and especially look you want
to talk about their ultimate crumb which
is really the which is really the one
that's better than the regular crumb
that ultimate crumb again two or three
bites you're going to go to New York
Deli they cut them into squares and they
put wrap them on and they're right at
the counter they wrap in Saran Wrap and
they have this much crumb and this much
cake the crumb you could take a bite of
it and go whoa and that's a two or three
bites you're like let me stop I'm
getting a sugar headache but that cake
sponge cake that's on the bottom of that
crumb is always dry and
you just take a piece of the cake and
put it in your mouth it's a tasteless
piece
when you get a buttery buttery on top
babe buttery's on top of the crumb no no
no when that bottom cake is made
properly it's a it's like a good pound
cake it's buttery I'm telling you right
now whether it be Entenmann's or whether
it be at a bakery or one in a bodega
that bottom cake to me is always for
some reason completely stale and dried
out always
as cauliflower wings
it's fight on sight food if you offer me
dessert and bring me a vegetable in
Disguise I should not be held respond
that's insane to call it a vegetable in
Disguise it's insane I just made one
from scratch this three cups of carrots
and there's a [ __ ] ton of everything
else carrots comprise you know like a
small portion of it that's wild it's
like saying you can't have anything
listen to this Loony Tunes lady I have
never tasted none of the two cakes but I
voted for crumb cake because I could
suppose that that could be delicious
who's never had either of these kids
yeah where are you from I'm going to say
one last thing about crumb cake and this
is let's just talk style let's just talk
aesthetic crumb cake is class dude
hold on hold on now
yo eats crumb cake
crumb cake
New York mob there's you don't think
they're sitting who Teamsters at the
meeting dude Teamsters at the meeting at
2 A.M they're still trying to work out
the deal that's when the crumb cake is
coming out and you just called it class
yeah
you said you know what it is you know
what it is it's class the mob and the
teamsters the man's man's King what are
you talking about carrot cake is class I
loved my nana dearly but carrot Cake's a
Nana cake that's class Nah The Mob has
more class than your grandmother you
never knew my grandmother okay I don't
think you know the mob it does feel like
Sal's cake has an identity and yours
rides on coffee being involved thank you
bro thank you bro nice to see you again
I don't I don't have a problem with that
it's like it's like look Bagels right on
cream cheese being involved right like
something something's just yes but yours
would be the feature and his would be
the headliner no way dude dude my carrot
cake my carrot cakes is a goddamn Robin
your crumb cake is a [ __ ] pig take a
look at me how many buffets do you think
I've been to In My Life plenty it's
plenty right yeah plenty no it's always
sitting in there you know it's always
sitting in excess at that dessert
counter the carrot cake nobody's
grabbing it there's no crumb cake it
sits there there's crumb cake sometimes
sometimes but that carrot cake sits
there dude I'm telling you it's heavy
it's chewy it's got a it's got a weird
texture where things are it's almost
tastes like there's like toenails or
something in it as you're eating it
there's like hard pieces in it as you're
eating it's raisins walnuts and shredded
carrots with butter powder oil eggs bro
it's just gross it's just it's so good
and it went and it's and it's moist and
delicious I'd rather cut out and eat my
own dirty [ __ ] than carrot cake oh my
God what is wrong with people crumb cake
he's lying by the way way crumb cake is
just lying no I read that I wasn't
myself he's lying I don't know well you
know he wouldn't rather cut out and eat
his own dirty [ __ ] than character
apparently that's absurd crumb cake is
an Abomination made of the leftover
drippings of other more delicious foods
crumb cake is wonderful cake is
wonderful you never know what you get
okay hold on Carrick
carrot cake is moist delicious with
cream cheese frosting can't be beat
crumb cake is Hit or Miss drier than a
[ __ ] oh he turned on you he
said both are garbage and lacks real
flavor whoo
anyone wait wait Pips there you go no no
slide back and anyone who doesn't choose
carrot cake is just perpetually stuck
child whining about gross vegetables
thank you okay all right it's the best
spice cake with the most delicious
frosting the best part about crumb cake
is not even a cake it's the crumb spice
that's true it should be it should be
called it should be called a crumb
cake carrot cake is a treat your weird
aunt would give you when you were forced
to spend holidays at her house why is
she weird because she makes a great
[ __ ] cake
from the concept of your crumb cake is
like me making a carrot cake with this
much carrot a carrot cake and then this
much carrot cake icing you understand
don't don't not pay attention to my
point don't no pay attention my point
you got this much cake in a crumb cake
and not much crumb it's a it's a rip-off
it's smoking mirrors right they're
trying to get you to call a cake all
you're doing is eating big gloves crumb
cakes you're eating that have this much
crumb and this much cake that's not how
they're made that's how they are in New
York delis that's how they are even the
entrance if you have an entenman's
ultimate versus the regular you're going
for the ultimate it's it's like it's
like all right ultimate it's like an 80
to 20 ratio
but my point is is that you're calling
it a cake and it's 80 not cake like for
me that's like that would be like me
making a carrot cake this thin and then
putting six inches of icing on it you're
trying to sell the cake from the cup
that's not true that's not true all
right you want to play that game take
away your precious cream cheese icing
and what are you left with yeah but
cream cheese is not the star of the show
it's a compliment the crumbs are a
compliment no the crumbs no I think the
crumbs with the cake are the or what
make it good I don't think either alone
is is better than the other [ __ ]
because if I just gave you crumb just
like the top of the month I don't want
just crumbs you would eat just crumb I
don't want you to you like eating just
ice cream I don't I wouldn't like kid I
like them both together people take the
crumbles
you know you do it
just taking the crumb off the top and
pop the crumb while you were eating it
a Drakes is amazing it is an amazing
balance of the two it is buttery it's
delicious it was Newman's favorite cake
that means something hello Joey all
right let's go back to the phones yes
fat mommy shout out no one's favorite
cake actually is not a good thing for
you fat mommy got jodarosa stinks on his
leg tattooed that's unbelievable
yeah shout out to you mentioned before
there was a person named rebs on YouTube
wait wait wait who has a taste buds
Bingo board that she made oh that would
be fun send that in and then someone
else I forget his name Joel or something
or other you know who you are uh gave a
good suggestion I just want to give a
little shout out he said our lightning
rounds could also be called bite-sized
battles oh that's very good yes it is
all right let's read a couple more
phones then we gotta we gotta go we
gotta grab this more like crummy cake
why not just eat a circle of dust that's
funny I laughed very hard at unless
you're in a retirement home or Bugs
Bunny I don't know who's voting for
carrot cake carrot cake all the way
however raisins are disgusting and hot
raisins taste like little pimples and
desserts incorrect you know you're not
eating a hot raisin who's eating a hot
raisin this was tough but I had to go
with crumb cake nothing like choking on
a dry ass crumb cake to really get your
blood sugar going all the points I made
it's illegal to vote on multiple
accounts because I love carrot cake so
much okay
three words cream cheese frosting baboon
carrot cake is the heart burn is
heartburning cake form welcome back
Sally babes
carrot cake is better for the eyes crumb
cake give me a carrot with cream cheese
frosting I'm allergic to walnuts I'll
fight
yeah but I I like I said I subbed pecans
for walnuts it's just the point you know
I would give the I would give the dirty
[ __ ] comment to win
it would just made us laugh very hard
all right follow Roger at notorious r
GA I'd like Roger to prove this please
I'm like Roger to prove it all right
here we go ready
drum roll where are we at pennies
where we at
what time what time we have babe
okay okay six thousand votes not a ton
of votes but we just put it in
uh all right do you want anything to say
before we I I really thought that um
I thought crumb cake is is just more
common I thought it was more a more
popular cake and so I thought going into
this battle that crumb cake had the
upper hand uh I felt like I was fighting
uphill but according to the comments it
might be closer than I think I had faith
in crumb cake and the caramets seemed to
be supporting that notion but let's see
all right where you going with it
all right
now we're talking drum roll uh that was
this is the The Humble Pie uh pimp you
still doing a thing where it rolls in
and okay so 59.3 crumb cake to 40.7
carrot cake it wasn't uh too bad of a
battle there but it was good
I still love you buddy I love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate
bug